today we are revisiting lafayette
louisiana david's hometown to catch up
with two families brought together by
chance through a little boy who's now
four years old they would never have met
but for the memory of one very special
man
when this baby boy entered the world in
lafayette louisiana in 2018
his parents connie despanney and
benjamin hall named him
kingston
but they didn't have a middle name
it came to them by chance
in the form of a handwritten letter that
they had received at the hospital
kingston was just minutes old
a surveillance camera at lafayette
general medical center captured a
stranger asking for directions so that
she could deliver that letter who was
she to my dad's angel
even though i will never know your name
you are the first child born here
after my dad's passing when one life is
taken
another is given please keep my dad in
your prayers his name is james thank you
this was that stranger
jamie fontenot you see shortly after her
father 86 year old james lee gremet died
in the hospital jamie heard sweet music
[Music]
it's a lullaby that plays throughout the
hospital
families of newborns come here and they
press that button in the labor and
delivery ward playing the lullaby
letting everybody know
a newborn just arrived
on january 12 2018
kingston hall was born
right after mr gremet died the timing
seemed more than coincidental somebody
said well then that's dad's angel
so with no escort you just took your
letter and i just took my letter and i
went to the ob unit i said my dad passed
away about 10 40.
so give this to the first baby that was
born
after that time dr jennifer puglisi and
nurse sydney begno
received jamie's letter
dr puglisi gave it to connie and she
started reading it silently and she just
had tears streaming down down her face
and
it was really beautiful i came in and
the dad says oh we found our middle name
and i'm like great what is it and he
says well it's james of course
and i'm like oh yes of course my nurse
followed me to that side and she was
like well
do you mind if we get your information
and give it to miss jamie
we asked connie do you remember who that
nurse was i know her name was i think
miss cindy
sydney sydney
yes i think it was sitting near sydney
so that's my mom
really
what a coincidence
that's awesome thank you mom yes it was
my mom who helped to deliver baby
kingston and then told me the story of
how a stranger wrote a letter to connie
who then decided that the best middle
name for kingston was james
named in honor of mr grimmit
i'm so happy you came i'm happy to meet
you
i you think i was going to meet you
i think i'd ever see you either
the best part for jamie
holding
kingston james
what
are we
to take away from a story like this
family is everything
and if you
don't have faith
you don't have anything you just never
know when a blessing is going to come
and fall in your lap so you all will
stay in touch of course of course
we all want to clap so we're just going
to clap
well that was four years ago
how are you now
good good great everybody's great yes
blessed
blessed
[Music]
how big you are this is actually the
first time they've seen each other since
the pandemic started he got it mastered
mom baby kingston just started pre-k
there you go
when you see him do you think about your
dad always yeah yes yeah
always and my name is hanson james
hall what does it do for you when you
hear him say his name do you think about
her dad
yes and how far he's came in kingston
he loves to say his name does he yes
he'll tell you i'm kingston james hall
and i said well go ahead baby
i can't even describe it because he's
here and on top of that he was blessed
with an angel that's right
coming into the world jamie has been
following every milestone even putting
together a special picture book for
kingston's baptism he was 86 years old i
wanted something you know sort of set in
stone
that he could have through the years
that he could look back at when he was
born
and the story behind
what happened what's happened between
the two of you in the last four years
well we
we talk
we text she sends pictures what do you
hope this story does for other people
share that
good things still happen
that
strangers can become family like
everybody can come on one accord right
and love one another unconditionally
without even knowing each other that's
it yeah yes definitely
[Music]
strangers can become family peace love
it oh my god i'm tempted to clap as you
did in the piece yeah i know right now
it's a great reunion uh what was it like
for you going back and seeing your mom
and and and this this other family
that's now so connected to yours look
it's gratifying because it's my
hometown right so i love telling stories
from home you know i remember when my
mom first told me about this story and
she didn't tell it very well and i went
to bed that night
you're like this is not a story i
thought i called her back the next day
and i said wait you delivered a baby and
they named the baby after the man she
goes yeah yeah yeah that's what happened
i was like mom that's a great story i
was like i gotta tell the story
so uh i love this connection that they
have and
this notion of unconditional love
between strangers between your neighbor
um all wrapped around in this little
bundle of joy and this guardian angel um
we need more of it right yeah before he
the day that he was born
it's an incredible story david really
well done well thank you thank you mama
thank
you took care of the storytelling you
got that part down but she gave you the
faith and the love and the belief in
families and the most important thing
and you can see that every day in your
storytelling you're right oh
thank you and and by the way mom is now
retired she gave covert shots at the
start of the pandemic did that and now
she's just enjoying those grandbabies hi
mom so you're supposed to say hi mom hi
mama